The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good morning,
everybody.
All right, I ended up the last
lecture talking about how to
calculate the absolute
goodness of fit using
something called the coefficient
of determination.
It's usually spelled as
R-squared, or R2.
And the formula was
quite simple.
We measure the goodness of the
fit as R-squared equals 1
minus the estimated
error divided by
the measured variance.
As I observed, R-squared always
lies between 0 and 1.
If R-squared equals 1, that
means that the model that we
constructed, the predicted
values if you will, explains
all of the variability in the
data so that any change in the
data is explained perfectly
by the model.
We don't usually get 1.
In fact, if I ever got
1, I would think
somebody cheated me.
R-squared equals 0, or
conversely, it means there's
no linear relationship at all
between the values predicted
by the model and the
actual data.
That is to say, the model
is totally worthless.
So we have code here, the top
of the screen, showing how
easy it is to compute
R-squared.
And for those of you who have a
little trouble interpreting
the formula, because maybe
you're not quite sure what EE
and MV mean, this will give you
a very straightforward way
to understand it.
So now, we can run it.
We can get some answers.
So if we look at it, you'll
remember last time, we looked
at two different fits.
We looked at a quadratic fit
and a linear fit for the
trajectory of an arrow
fired from my bow.
And we can now compare
the two.
And not surprisingly, given what
we know about the physics
of projectiles, we see it is
exactly what we'd expect, that
the linear fit has an R-quared
of 0.0177, showing that, in
fact, it explains almost
none of the data.
Whereas the quadratic fit has
a really astonishingly good
R-squared of 0.98, saying that
almost all of the changes in
the values of the variables,
that is to say the way the y
value changes with respect
to the x value, is
explained by the model.
i.e., we have a really
good model of
the physical situation.
Very comforting.
Essentially, it's telling us
at less than 2% of the
variation is explained by the
linear model, 98% by the
quadratic model.
Presumably the other 2%
is experimental error.
Well, now that we know that we
have a really good model of
the data, we can ask the
question, why do we care?
We have the data itself.
What's the point of building
a model of the data?
And that, of course, is what
we're getting when we run
polyfit to get this curve.
The whole purpose of creating
a model, or an important
purpose of creating a model,
is to be able to answer
questions about the actual
physical situation.
So one of the questions one
might ask, for example, about
firing an arrow is, how
fast is it going?
That's kind of a useful thing
to know if you're worried
about whether it will penetrate
a target and kill
somebody on the other
side, for example.
We can't answer that
question directly
looking at the data points.
You look at the data.
Well, I don't know.
But we can use the model
to answer the question.
And that's an exercise I want to
go through now to show you
the interplay between models,
and theory, and computation,
and how we can use the three to
answer relevant questions
about data.
No, I do not want to check for
new software, thank you.
In fact, let's make sure it
won't do that anymore.
So let's look at
the PowerPoint.
So here, we'll see how I'm using
a little bit of theory,
not very much, to be able to
understand how to use the
model to compute the
speed of the arrow.
So what we see is we know by
our model, and by the good
fit, that the trajectory is
given by y equals ax-squared
plus bx plus c.
We know that.
We also know from looking at
this equation that the highest
point, which I'll call yPeak,
of the arrow must occur at
xMid, the middle
of the x-axis.
So if we look at a parabola, and
it doesn't matter what the
parabola is, we always know
that the vertical peak is
halfway along the x-axis.
The math tells us that
from the equation.
So we can say yPeak is x times
xMid squared plus b
times xMid plus c.
So now, we have a model that
we can tell how high
the arrow can get.
The next question I'll ask is
if I fired the arrow from
here, and it hits the
target here--
I've exaggerated
by it this way.
It's nowhere near this steep.
How long does it take to
get from here to here?
We don't have anything about
time in our data.
Yet, I claim we have enough
information to go from the
distance here and the distance
here to how long it's going to
take the arrow to get from
here to the target.
Why do I know that?
What determines how long it's
going to take to get
from here to here?
It's going to be how long it
takes it to fall that far.
It's going to be gravity.
Because we know that gravity, at
least on this planet, is a
constant or close
enough to it.
Unless maybe the arrow were
going a million miles.
And it's going to be gravity
that tells me how long it
takes to get from
here to here.
And when it gets to the bottom,
it's going to be here,
So again, I can use some very
simple math and say that the
time will be the square root of
2 times the yPeak divided
by the gravitational constant.
Because I know that however long
it takes to get from this
height to this height is going
to be the same time it takes
to get from this point
to this point.
And that will therefore let me
compute the average speed from
here to here.
And once I know that,
I'm done.
Now again, this is assuming no
drag and things like that.
The thing that we always have to
understand about a model is
no model is actually
ever correct.
On the other hand, many models
are very useful and they're
close enough to correct.
So I left out things like
gravity, wind shear
and stuff like that.
But in fact, the answer we get
here will turn out to be very
close to correct.
We can now go back and
look at some code.
Get rid of this.
And so now, you'll see
this on the handout.
I'm going to just write a little
bit of code that just
goes through the math I just
showed you to compute the
average x velocity.
Got a print statement here
I use to debug it.
And I'm going to return it.
And then, we'll just be able to
run it and see what we get.
Well, all right, that
we looked at before.
I forgot to close the
previous figure.
So now, I'm sure this is a
problem you've all seen.
And we'll fix it the
way we always fix
things, just start over.
I'll bet you guys have also
seen this happen.
What this is suggesting, as
we've seen before, is that the
process, the old process,
still exists.
Not a good thing.
Again, I'm sure you've
all seen these.
Let's make sure we don't have
anything running here that
looks like IDLE.
We don't.
Just takes it a little time.
There it is, all right.
All right, now we'll go back.
All of this happened because I
forgot to close the figure and
executed pyLab.show twice,
which we know
can lead to bad things.
So let's get rid of this.
Now, we'll run it.
And now, we have our figure just
using the quadratic fit.
And we see that the speed is
136.25 feet per second.
Do I believe 136.25?
Not really.
I know it's the ballpark.
I confused precision with
accuracy here by giving you it
to two decimal places.
I can compute it as precisely
as I want.
But that doesn't mean it's
actually accurate.
Probably, I should have just
said it's about 135 or
something like that.
But it's pretty good.
And for those of who don't know
how to do this arithmetic
in your head like me, this is
about 93 miles per hour.
And for comparison, the speed of
sound, instead of 136 feet
per second, is 1,100
feet per second.
So it's traveling pretty fast.
Well, what's the
point of this?
I don't really care
if you know how
fast an arrow travels.
I don't expect you'll ever
need to compute that.
But I wanted to show you this
as an example of a pattern
that we use a lot.
So what we did is we started
with an experiment.
You didn't see this, but I
actually stood in my backyard
and shot a bunch of arrows and
measured them, got real data
out of that.
And this gave me some data
about the behavior of a
physical system.
That's what I get for
wearing a tie.
Maybe it'll be quieter if
I put it in my shirt.
Actually, it looks silly.
Excuse me.
I hope none of you will mind
if I take my tie off?
It seems to be making noises
in the microphone.
Maybe we should write
a computation.
All right, so ends my
experiment with
trying to look dignified.
Not something I'm good at.
OK, had an experiment.
That gave us some data.
We then use computation to both
find and very importantly
evaluate a model.
It's no good just to
find the model.
You need to do some evaluation
to convince yourself that it's
a good model of the actual
physical system.
And then, finally, we use some
theory and analysis and
computation to derive the
consequence of the model.
And then, since we believe the
accuracy of the model, we
assume this consequence was
also a true fact about the
physical system we
started with.
This is a pattern that we see
over and over again these days
in all branches of science
and engineering.
And it's just the kind
of thing that you
should get used to doing.
It is what you will do if you go
onto a career in science or
engineering.
OK, that's all I want to say
now about the topic of data
and experiments and analysis.
We will return to this topic
of interpretation of data
later in the semester near the
end when we start talking
about machine learning
and clustering.
But for now, I want to pull
back and start down a new
track that will, I'm sure you'll
be pleased to hear,
dovetail nicely with the next
few problem sets that you're
going to have to work on.
What I want to talk about is
the topic of optimization.
Not so much optimization in the
sense of how do you make a
program fast, though we will
talk a little about that, but
what people refer to as
optimization problems.
How do we write programs to
find optimal solutions to
problems that occur
in real life?
Every optimization problem
we'll look at is
going to have two parts.
There's going to be (1) an
objective function that will
either be maximized
or minimized.
So for example, I might want to
find the minimal air fare
between Boston and Istanbul.
Or more likely, the minimum
bus fare between
Boston and New York.
So there's an objective
function.
Sometimes, you find the least.
Sometimes, you find the most.
Maybe I want to maximize
my income.
And (2) a set of constraints
that have to be satisfied.
So maybe I want to find the
minimum transportation,
minimum cost transportation
between Boston and New York
subject to the constraint that
it not take more than eight
hours or some such thing.
So the objective function that
you're minimizing or
maximizing, and some
set of constraints
that must be obeyed.
A vast number of problems of
practical importance can be
formulated this way.
Once we've formulated in this
systematic way, we can then
think about how to attack them
with a computation that will
help us solve the problem.
You guys do this all the time.
I heard a talk yesterday by
Jeremy Wertheimer, an MIT
graduate, who founded a
company called ITA.
If you ever use Kayak, for
example, or many of these
systems to find an airline
fare, they use some of
Jeremy's code and algorithms
to solve these various
optimization problems
like this.
If you've ever used Google or
Bing, they solve optimization
problems to decide what
pages to show you.
They're all over the place.
There are a lot of classic
optimization problems that
people have worked
on for decades.
What we often do when confronted
with a new problem,
and it's something you'll get
some experience on in problem
sets, is take a seemingly new
problem and map it onto a
classic problem, and then use
one of the classic solutions.
So we'll go through this
section of the course.
And we'll look at a number of
classic optimization problems.
And then, you can think about
how you would map other
problems onto those.
This is the process known as
problem reduction, where we
take a problem and map it onto
an existing problem that we
already know how to solve.
I'm not going to go through a
list of classic optimization
problems right now.
But we'll see a bunch of
them as we go forward.
Now, an important thing to
think about when we think
about optimization problems
is how long, how
hard, they are to solve.
So far, we have looked at
problems that, for the most
part, have pretty fast
solutions, often sub-linear,
binary search, sometimes linear,
and at worst case,
low-order polynomials.
Optimization problems, as we'll
see, are typically much
worse than that.
In fact, what we'll see
is there is often no
computationally efficient
way to solve them.
And so we end up dealing with
approximate solutions to them,
or what people might call
best effort solutions.
And we see that as
an increasing
trend in tackling problems.
All right, enough of this
abstract stuff.
Let's look at an example.
So one of the classic
optimization problems is
called the knapsack problem.
People know what
a knapsack is?
Sort of an archaic term.
Today, people would use
the word backpack.
But in the old days, they called
them knapsacks when
they started looking
at these things.
And the problem is also
discussed in the context of a
burglar or various
kinds of thieves.
So it's not easy being a
burglar, by the way.
I don't know if any of
you ever tried it.
You've got some of the obvious
problems, like making sure the
house is empty and
picking locks,
circumventing alarms, et cetera.
But one of the really hard
problems a burglar has to deal
with is deciding
what to steal.
Because you break into the
typical luxury home-- and why
would you break into a
poor person's house
if you were a burglar--
there's usually far more to
steal than you can carry away.
And so the problem is formulated
in terms of the
burglar having a backpack.
They can put a certain amount
of stuff in it.
And they have to maximize the
value of what they steal
subject to the constraint of
how much weight they can
actually carry.
So it's a classic optimization
problem.
And people have worked for years
at how to solve it, not
so much because they want
to be burglars.
But as you'll see, these kinds
of optimization problems are
actually quite common.
So let's look at an example.
You break into the house.
And among other things,
you have a
choice of what to steal.
You have a rather strange
looking clock, some artwork, a
book, a Velvet Elvis in case
you lean in that direction,
all sorts of things.
And for some reason, the owner
was nice enough to leave you
information about how much
everything cost and how much
it weighed.
So you find this
piece of paper.
And now, you're trying to decide
what to steal based
upon this in a way to
maximize your value.
How do we go about doing it?
Oh, I should show
you, by the way.
There's a picture of
a typical knapsack.
All right, it's almost
Easter, after all.
Well, the simplest solution is
probably a greedy algorithm.
And we'll talk a lot about
greedy algorithms because they
are very popular and often
the right way to
tackle a hard problem.
So the notion of a greedy
algorithm is it's iterative.
And at each step, you pick the
locally optimal solution.
So you make the best choice, put
that item in the knapsack.
Ask if you have room, if
you're out of weight.
If not, you make the best choice
of the remaining ones.
Ask the same question.
You do that until you can't
fit anything else in.
Now of course, to do that, that
assumes that we know at
each stage what we mean
by locally optimal.
And of course, we have
choices here.
We're trying to figure out,
in some sense, what greedy
algorithm, what approach to
being greedy, will give us the
best result.
So one could, for example,
say, all right.
At each step, I'll choose the
most valuable item and put
that in my knapsack.
And I'll do that till I run
out of valuable items.
Or, you could, at each step,
say, well, what I'm really
going to choose is the one
that weights the least.
That will give me
the most items.
And maybe that will give
me the most total
value when I'm done.
Or maybe, at each step, you
could say, well, let me choose
the one that has the best
value to weight ratio
and put that in.
And maybe that will give
me the best solution.
As we will see, in this case,
none of those is guaranteed to
give you the best solution
all the time.
In fact, as we'll see, none of
them is guaranteed to be
better than any of the
others all the time.
And that's one of the issues
with greedy algorithms.
I should point out, by the way,
that this version of the
knapsack problem that we're
talking about is typically
called the 0/1 knapsack
problem.
And that's because we either
have to take the entire item
or none of the item.
We're not allowed to cut the
Velvet Elvis in half and take
half of it.
This is in contrast to the
continuous knapsack problem.
If you imagine you break into
the house and you see a barrel
of gold dust, and a barrel of
silver dust, and a barrel of
raisins, what you would do is
you would fill your knapsack
with as much gold as you
could carry, or until
you ran out of gold.
And then, you would fill it
with as much silver as you
could carry.
And then, if there's
any room left,
you'd put in the raisins.
For the continuous knapsack
problem, a greedy algorithm
provides an optimal solution.
Unfortunately, most of the
problems we actually encounter
in life, as we'll see, are
0/1 knapsack problems.
You either take something
or you don't.
And that's more complicated.
All right, let's look
at some code.
So I'm going to formulate it.
I'm first going to start by
putting in a class, just so
the rest of my code
is simpler.
This is something we've been
talking about, that
increasingly people want to
start by putting in some
useful data abstractions.
So I've got a class item where
I can put in the item.
I can get its name.
I get its value.
I can get its weight.
And I can print it.
Kind of a boring class,
but useful to have.
Then, I'm going to use this
class to build items.
And in this case, I'm going to
build the items based upon
what we just looked at,
the table that--
I think it's in your hand out.
And it's also on this slide.
Later, if we want, we can have
a randomized program to build
up a much bigger choice
of items.
But here, we'll just try the
clock, the painting, the
radio, the vase, the book,
and the computer.
Now comes the interesting
part.
I've written a function, greedy,
that takes three
arguments--
the set of items that I have to
choose from, makes sense,
the maximum weight the
burglar can carry.
And there's something called
key function, which is
defining essentially what I
mean by locally optimal.
Then, it's quite simple.
I'm going to sort the items
using the key function.
Remember, sort has this optional
argument that says,
what's the ordering?
So maybe I'll order
it by value.
Maybe I'll order
it by density.
Maybe I'll order it by weight.
I'm going to reverse it,
because I want the most
valuable first, not the least
valuable, for example.
And then, I'm going to just
take the first thing on my
list until I run out of weight,
and then I'm done.
And I'll return the result
and the total value.
To make life simple, I'm going
to define some functions.
These are the functions that
I can use for the ordering.
Value, which is just return
the value of the item.
The inverse of the weight,
because I'm thinking, as a
greedy algorithm, I'll take the
lightest, not the heaviest.
And since I'm reversing it,
I want to do the inverse.
And the density, which
is just the value
divided by the weight.
OK, make sense to everybody?
You with me?
Speak now, or not.
And then, we'll test it.
So again, kind of a theme of
this part of the course.
As we write these more complex
programs, we tend to have to
worry about our test
harnesses.
So I've got a function that
tests the greedy algorithm,
and then another function that
tests all three greedy
approaches--
the one algorithm with
different functions--
and looks at what
our results are.
So let's run it.
See what we get.
Oh, you know what I did?
Just the same thing
I did last time.
But this time, I'm going
to be smarter.
We're going to get rid of this
figure and comment out the
code that generated it.
And now, we'll test the
greedy algorithms.
So we see the items we had to
choose from, which I printed
using the string function
and items.
And if I use greedy by value to
fill a knapsack of size 20,
we see that I end up getting
just the computer if I do
greedy by value.
This is for the nerd burglar.
If I use weight, I
get a different--
I get more things, not
surprisingly --
but lower value.
And if I use density, I also
get four things, but four
different things, and I
get a higher value.
So I see that I can run these
greedy algorithms.
I can get an answer.
But it's not always
the same answer.
As I said earlier, greedy
by density happens
to work best here.
But you shouldn't assume that
will always be the case.
I'm sure you can all imagine
a different assignment of
weights and values that would
make greedy by density give
you a bad answer.
All right, before we
talk about how good
these answers are--
and we will come back to that
as, in particular, suppose I
want the best answer--
I want to stop for a minute and
talk about the algorithmic
efficiency of the greedy
algorithm.
So let's go back and
look at the code.
And this is why people use
greedy algorithms.
Actually, there are
two reasons.
One reason is that they're easy
to program, and that's
always a good thing.
And the other is that they are
typically highly efficient.
So what's the efficiency
of this?
How would we think about
the efficiency
of this greedy algorithm?
What are we looking at here?
Well, the first thing we have
to ask is, what's the first
thing it does?
It sorts the list, right?
So one thing that governs the
efficiency might be the amount
of time it takes to sort
the list of items.
Well, we know how
long that takes.
Or we can speculate at least.
And let's assume it does
something like merge sort.
So what's that term
going to be?
Order what?
Len of items times what?
Log n, right?
So maybe that's going
to tell us the
complexity, but maybe not.
The next thing we have to do is
look at the while loop and
see how many times are we going
through the while loop.
What's the worst case?
Somebody?
I know I didn't bring any candy
today, but you could
answer the question anyway.
Be a sport.
Do it for free.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The length
of the items.
PROFESSOR: Well, we know
this one is bigger.
So it looks like that's
the complexity, right?
So we can say, all right,
pretty good.
Slightly worse than linear in
the length of the items, but
not bad at all.
And that's a big attraction
of greedy algorithms.
They are typically order length
of items, or order
length of items times the
log of the length.
So greedy algorithms are usually
very close to linear.
And that's why we really
like them.
Why we don't like them is it may
be that the accumulation
of a sequence of locally optimal
solutions does not
yield a globally optimal
solution.
So now, let's ask the question,
suppose that's not
good enough.
I have a very demanding thief.
Or maybe the thief works for
a very demanding person and
needs to choose the absolute
optimal set.
Let's think first about how we
formulate that carefully.
And then, what the complexity
of solving it would be.
And then, algorithms that
might be useful.
Again, the important step here,
I think, is not the
solution to the problem, but the
process used to formulate
the problem.
Often, it is the case that once
one has done a careful
formulation of a problem, it
becomes obvious how to solve
it, at least in a
brute force way.
So now, let's look at a
formalization of the 0/1
knapsack problem.
And it's a kind of formalization
we'll use for a
lot of problems.
So step one, we'll represent
each item by a pair.
Because in fact, in deciding
whether or not to take an
item, we don't care
what its name.
We don't care if it's a clock,
or a radio, or whatever.
What matters is what's its value
and what's its weight.
We'll write W as the maximum
weight that the thief can
carry, or that can fit
in the knapsack.
So far, so good.
Nothing complicated there.
Now comes the interesting
step.
We're going to represent
the set of
available items as a vector.
We'll call it I. And then we'll
have another vector, V,
which indicates whether or not
each item in I has been taken.
So V is a vector.
And if V_i is equal to
1, that implies I_i--
big I sub little i--
has been taken, is
in the knapsack.
Conversely, if V_i is
0, it means I_i
is not in the knapsack.
So having formulated the
situation thusly, we can now
go back to our notion of an
optimization problem as an
objective function and a set
of constraints to carefully
state the problem.
So for the objective function,
we want to maximize the sum of
V_i times I_i dot value, where
i ranges over the length of
the vectors.
So that's the trick
of the 0/1.
If I don't take it, it's 0.
So it's 0 times the value.
If I take it, it's 1
times the value.
So this is going to give me the
sum of the values of the
items I've taken.
And then, I have this subject
to the constraint.
And again, we'll
do a summation.
And it will look very similar.
V_i times I_i, but this time,
dot weight is less than or
equal to W.
Straightforward, but a
useful kind of skill.
And people do spend a lot
of time on doing that.
If you've ever used MATLAB, you
know it wants everything
to be a vector.
And that's often because a lot
of these problems can be
nicely formulated in
this kind of way.
All right, now let's return to
the question of complexity.
What happens if we implement
this in the most
straightforward way?
What would the most
straightforward
implementation look like?
Well, we could enumerate all
possibilities and then choose
the best that meets
the constraint.
So this would be the obvious
brute force solution to the
optimization problem.
Look at all possible
solutions.
Choose the best one.
I think you can see immediately
that this is
guaranteed to give you
the optimal solution.
Actually, an optimal solution.
Maybe there's more
than one best.
But in that case, you can just
choose whichever one you like
or whichever comes first,
for example.
The question is, how long
will this take to run?
Well, we can think about that
by asking the question, how
big will this set be?
How many possibilities
are there?
Well, we can think about that
in a pretty straightforward
way because if we look at our
formulation, we can ask
ourselves, how many possible
vectors are there?
How many vector V's could there
be which shows which
items were taken and
which weren't?
And what's the answer to that?
Well, if we have n items,
how long will V be?
Length n, right?
0, 1 for each.
If we have a vector of 0's and
1''s of length n, how many
different values can that
vector take on?
We asked this question before.
What's the answer?
Somebody shout it out.
I've got a vector of length n.
Every value in the vector
is either a 0 or a 1.
So maybe it looks something
like this.
How many possible combinations
of (0, 1)'s are there?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the n?
PROFESSOR: 2 to the n.
Because essentially, this is
a binary number, exactly.
And so if I had an n-bit binary
number, I can represent
2 to the n different values.
And so we see that we have 2 to
the n possible combinations
to look at if we use a
brute force solution.
How bad is this?
Well, if the number of items
is small, it's not so bad.
And you'll see that, in fact, I
can run this on the example
we've looked.
2 to the 5 is not
a huge number.
Suppose I have a different
number.
Suppose I have 50 items
to choose from.
Not a big problem.
I heard yesterday that the
number of different airfares
between two cities in the
US is order of 500 --
500 different airfares between,
say, Boston and Chicago.
So looking at the best there
might be 2 to the 500, kind of
a bigger number.
Let's look at 2 to the 50.
Let's say there were
50 items to choose
from in this question.
And let's say for the sake
of argument, it takes a
microsecond, one millionth
of a second,
to generate a solution.
How long will it take to solve
this problem in a brute force
way for 50 items?
Who thinks you can do it
in under four seconds?
How about under four minutes?
Wow, skeptics.
Four hours?
That's a lot of computation.
Four hours, you're starting
to get some people.
Four days?
All right.
Well, how about four years?
Still longer, just under
four decades?
Looking at one choice every
microsecond, it takes you
roughly 36 years to evaluate
all these possibilities.
Certainly for people of my age,
that's not a practical
solution to have to wait
36 years for an answer.
So we have to find
something better.
And we'll be talking
about that later.